Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha
Jake:真好玩
Jake: This is really fun
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Lucia: 为什么我不能在想断的地方把它断掉
Lucia: Why can't I break it where I want to?
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Alice:因为断不了
Alice: Because it won't break
Jake:挺好挺好这样挺好
Jake: It's fine, it's fine, this is fine
Lucia: 下去你给我下去
Lucia: Get down, get down
Lucia: 但是他这个这里
Lucia: But here, this part
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
Lucia: 要再来一个吗
Lucia: Should we do another one?
Alice:来一个
Alice: Let's do one
Alice:没让我弄个平
Alice: Didn't let me make it flat
Alice:哦了
Alice: Oh, it's done
Lucia: 哇这个好平
Lucia: Wow, this is so flat
Jake:可以很平
Jake: It can be very flat
Lucia: 那我再来挤一个好了
Lucia: Then I'll squeeze another one
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Tasha: 挤的各有特色
Tasha: Each squeeze has its own style
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Tasha: 哦我还以为你就这样断了
Tasha: Oh, I thought you broke it like that
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Lucia: 没有本来想给他画个什么花
Lucia: No, I wanted to draw something on it
Lucia: 结果发现画了一个圈之后
Lucia: Then I realized after drawing a circle
Lucia: 也画不出什么了
Lucia: I couldn't draw anything else
Lucia: 这好奇怪啊
Lucia: This is so weird
Katrina: 像蜡烛
Katrina: Looks like a candle
Lucia: 像拔青一样呵
Lucia: Looks like pulling weeds, ha
Jake:挺好
Jake: It's fine
Tasha: 好了吗
Tasha: Is it done?
Lucia: 哈哈等一下
Lucia: Haha, wait a moment
Alice:这是食症
Alice: This is food poisoning
Jake:这是花
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Alice:祛湿症哈哈哈
Alice: It's for dampness relief, hahaha
Jake:呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:这草
Jake: This grass
Lucia: 谁再来一个
Lucia: Who wants to do another one?
Alice:可以画个笑脸
Alice: We could draw a smiley face.
Tasha: 我觉得有点多
Tasha: I think it's a bit too much.
Tasha: 大家可以多挤一点
Tasha: Everyone can squeeze a bit more.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 最后一个
Tasha: The last one.
Jake:呵压力很大
Jake: Oh, the pressure is high.
Tasha: 让杨老板挤一个盛大的开场
Tasha: Let Jake squeeze a grand opening.
Lucia: 对对对来个大的哈哈哈
Lucia: Yes, yes, make it big, hahaha.
Alice:可以吃了吗
Alice: Can we eat now?
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 嚯 怎么还剩这么多奶油
Tasha: Whoa, why is there still so much cream?
Tasha: 那这个是不是不要了
Tasha: Should we not use this?
Tasha: 草莓
Tasha: Strawberries.
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This one.
Alice:可以吃了吗
Alice: Can we eat now?
Lucia: 草莓放冰冰上吃
Lucia: Put the strawberries on the ice and eat.
Tasha: 吃
Tasha: Eat.
Jake:压力到我这边
Jake: The pressure is on me.
Tasha: 全部挤掉
Tasha: Squeeze it all out.
Lucia: 挤满吧
Lucia: Fill it up.
Tasha: 这就是你了
Tasha: This is yours.
Jake:挤满到我这边挤来
Jake: Fill it up and squeeze it to me.
Jake:哎这还行啊
Jake: Hey, this is not bad.
Lucia: 哎这还怪好看的
Lucia: Hey, this looks pretty good.
Lucia: 哎果然没有压力就是不一样
Lucia: See, no pressure makes a difference.
Jake:哦豁哈哈哈
Jake: Oh, haha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Tasha: 怎么办奶油太多
Tasha: What to do, there's too much cream.
Katrina: 这颜色好看
Katrina: This color looks nice.
Tasha: 还有那么多怎么办
Tasha: What to do with so much left?
Lucia: 给哪个少的再加一点
Lucia: Add a bit more to the ones with less.
Lucia: 如果哪位同学
Lucia: If any student
Jake:哎这样挺好
Jake: Hey, this is pretty good.
Lucia: 可以吃的话
Lucia: can eat it,
Lucia: 可以吃掉它
Lucia: they can eat it.
Lucia: 啊好看耶
Lucia: Ah, it looks nice.
Jake:水平还是高
Jake: The level is still high.
Tasha: 专业
Tasha: Professional.
Jake:巨石阵批发
Jake: Stonehenge wholesale.
Lucia: 巨石阵批发
Lucia: Stonehenge wholesale.
Jake:哎哎这个3个变成了10个
Jake: Hey, hey, these 3 have turned into 10.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha.
老板：哈哈哈哈哈
Boss: Hahahahaha.
Tasha: 完了完了
Tasha: Oh no, oh no.
Lucia: 小心小心
Lucia: Careful, careful.
Katrina: 喷出来了
Katrina: It's spilling out.
Katrina: 主打一个不浪费
Katrina: No waste is the key.
Alice:直接往里吸溜吧
Alice: Just slurp it up directly.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Katrina: 草莓
Katrina: Strawberry.
Katrina: 草莓奶油苹果
Katrina: Strawberry cream apple.
Tasha: 来点掌声
Tasha: Let's have some applause.
Alice:好我要这个
Alice: Okay, I want this one.
Jake:拍一张
Jake: Take a picture.
Alice:杨老板您的易路
Alice: Jake, your art.
Tasha: 艺术草莓
Tasha: Art strawberry.
Jake:哈哈我的艺术草莓
Jake: Haha, my art strawberry.
Alice:呵呵呵
Alice: Hehehe.
Jake:我的我的
Jake: Mine, mine.
Jake:挺好的我很开心
Jake: It's pretty good, I'm very happy.
Tasha: 呵呵
Tasha: Hehe.
Alice:哦了
Alice: Oh, done.
Tasha: 怎么办最后不浪费剪得好丑啊
Tasha: What to do, in the end, no waste but it looks ugly.
Jake:不丑啊这个各有特色
Jake: It's not ugly, each has its own charm.
Lucia: 对不丑不丑各有物色
Lucia: Yeah, not ugly, each has its own look.
Jake:真的是你远远看的
Jake: Really, when you look from afar.
Jake:真不知道是什么哈哈哈
Jake: You really have no idea what it is, hahaha.
Alice:我来接一个吧
Alice: Let me take one.
Lucia: 我先把我点的这个跟巨石阵一样
Lucia: I’ll eat the one I ordered that looks like Stonehenge.
Lucia: 给吃了吧
Lucia: Let's eat it.
Tasha: 人为艺术
Tasha: Human-made art.
Jake:谢谢谢谢您
Jake: Thank you, thank you.
Katrina: 再把我这个
Katrina: Then mine...
Jake:这该怎么下口呢
Jake: How should I bite into this?
Alice:先舔一下
Alice: Lick it first.
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Hehe.
Tasha: 扭一扭
Tasha: Twist it.
Jake:扭一扭泡一泡
Jake: Twist and soak.
Tasha: 其实需要勺子
Tasha: Actually, we need a spoon.
Jake:结果没有
Jake: But we don't have one.
Jake:那就硬吃是吧
Jake: So we just eat it straight, right?
Tasha: 嗯呵呵
Tasha: Yeah, haha.
Lucia: 嗯好好吃
Lucia: Hmm, it's really tasty.
Lucia: 这个奶油调的也好好
Lucia: This cream is also really good.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:第一视角是是是巨石阵
Jake: The first-person view is Stonehenge.
Jake:吃蛋糕
Jake: Eating cake.
Jake:眼线先吃
Jake: Eat the eyeliner first.
Jake:就就是这样
Jake: Just like this.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 好敬业哈哈哈
Lucia: So dedicated, hahaha.
Jake:呵呵呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehehehe.
Lucia: 我应该怎样才能把它撕开
Lucia: How should I tear this open?
Lucia: 哎呦吓我一跳
Lucia: Whoa, you scared me.
Jake:哎小心一点
Jake: Hey, be careful.
Alice:哎楼下这个厕所门是坏的
Alice: Hey, the bathroom door downstairs is broken.
Alice:还是上面的坏的
Alice: Or is it the one upstairs that's broken?
Lucia: 好像俩都是坏的
Lucia: I think both are broken.
Lucia: 是好的呀
Lucia: It's working though.
Alice:绝了
Alice: Unbelievable.
Jake:就就那个是好的
Jake: Only that one works.
Alice:就锁不了啊
Alice: But it won't lock.
Jake:就那个是好的应该
Jake: That one should be working.
Alice:那那洗澡的话
Alice: So, what about showering?
Katrina: 楼上的楼上的这个是好的
Katrina: The one upstairs works.
Lucia: 哦不这个是坏的
Lucia: Oh no, this one is broken.
Katrina: 我可以锁上
Katrina: I can lock it.
Lucia: 啊这个吗
Lucia: This one?
Katrina: 嗯就把他那个一拨一下就好
Katrina: Yeah, just flick it.
Lucia: 你说的是这边这个还是那边那个
Lucia: Are you talking about this side or the other side?
Katrina: 我你房间那个啊
Katrina: The one in your room.
Alice:这个是好的吗
Alice: Is this one okay?
Lucia: 啊那个不叫
Lucia: Ah, that one doesn't count.
Lucia: 反正我没锁上
Lucia: I couldn't lock it anyway.
Lucia: 也可能是我操作有误
Lucia: Maybe I did it wrong.
Katrina: 他不是往左还是往右
Katrina: Does it go left or right?
Jake:哎呀  完了
Jake: Oh man, it's over.
Katrina: 拨一下就可以锁上
Katrina: Just dial it and it will lock.
Alice:你可以从外面打开一下吗
Alice: Can you try opening it from the outside?
Alice:我看能锁上没
Alice: I want to see if it locks.
Jake:这个应该不行
Jake: This probably won't work.
Alice:嗯锁不了
Alice: Hmm, it won't lock.
Alice:坏滴7
Alice: It's broken.
Lucia: 大家一起烤的呵呵
Lucia: Everyone's baking together, haha.
Tasha: 就是他吃了之后会爆浆里面哦
Tasha: When he eats it, it'll burst with filling inside.
Lucia: 哦这么酷
Lucia: Oh, that's so cool!
Tasha: 啊这么酷
Tasha: Ah, that's so cool!
Lucia: 我一直以为
Lucia: I always thought...
Lucia: 这种东西
Lucia: This kind of thing...
Lucia: 就是只有蛋糕店才可以做出来
Lucia: Could only be made by a bakery.
Lucia: 就是单靠个人的力量是做不出来的
Lucia: Like, you couldn't make it on your own.
Lucia: 哈哈只有一种神秘力量才能做出来
Lucia: Haha, it takes some kind of mysterious power to make it.
Tasha: 你是不是不吃了
Tasha: Are you not eating anymore?
Lucia: 我们的神秘力量
Lucia: Our mysterious power.
Alice:哦我吃过两个
Alice: Oh, I've had two already.
Katrina: 等一会等一会吃嘛
Katrina: Wait a bit, wait a bit before eating.
Katrina: 我等一会就会消化
Katrina: I'll digest it in a bit.
Alice:谁没吃过两个
Alice: Who hasn't had two?
Katrina: 我还没吃过两个
Katrina: I haven't had two yet.
Lucia: 我还没吃过两个
Lucia: I haven't had two yet.
Tasha: 他还没吃啊
Tasha: He hasn't eaten yet.
Jake:啊我怎么没吃
Jake: Ah, how come I haven't eaten?
Jake:我刚吃完就没吃
Jake: I just ate, and then didn't eat.
Jake:哪个是我的
Jake: Which one's mine?
小薇;这个
Tasha: This one.
Katrina: 哎
Katrina: Hey...
Katrina: 谁看见我线了
Katrina: Has anyone seen my cable?
Jake:休息一下
Jake: Take a break.
Katrina: 就剩一个头了
Katrina: There's only the head left.
Alice:有点甜
Alice: It's a bit sweet.
Jake:什么线
Jake: What cable?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Jake:iPhone的线吗
Jake: The iPhone cable?
Tasha: 我不知道加了多少糖
Tasha: I don't know how much sugar I added.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Jake:iPhone的线
Jake: The iPhone cable.
Tasha: 加入了致死量的糖
Tasha: Added a lethal amount of sugar.
Alice:致死量的糖
Alice: A lethal dose of sugar.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Alice:快晕过去了
Alice: I'm getting dizzy.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Alice:啊被你甜晕了
Alice: Ah, I'm getting dizzy from your sweetness.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Alice: 你的甜蜜攻击
Alice: Your sweet attack.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Tasha: 好好好
Tasha: Alright, alright.
Alice:俘获我的心
Alice: Captured my heart.
Alice:哈哈好好好
Alice: Haha, alright, alright.
Tasha: 好好好
Tasha: Alright, alright.
Alice:我今天晚上想洗个澡
Alice: I want to take a bath tonight.
Tasha: 致死量的
Tasha: A lethal dose of...
Tasha: 你要不要去楼上洗
Tasha: Do you want to bathe upstairs?
Tasha: 额不过
Tasha: Umm, but...
Jake:喂他我
Jake: Hey, I...
Jake:我给你看一下
Jake: Let me show you something.
Jake:那是不是你
Jake: Is that you?
Alice:开了灯有有声音的话应该也没人进
Alice: If the light is on and there's noise, no one should come in.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Mm.
Lucia: 你去去楼上洗呗楼上全是女生
Lucia: You can bathe upstairs, it's all girls up there.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Mm.
Alice:哎明天不想化妆了化妆好累还得卸
Alice: Ugh, I don't want to put on makeup tomorrow, it's so tiring and then you have to remove it.
Alice:哎我现在只想躺床上睡觉
Alice: Ugh, I just want to lie in bed and sleep now.
Tasha: 呵呵
Tasha: Hehe.
Katrina: 你们一般几点睡
Katrina: What time do you guys usually sleep?
Alice:我昨天3点多睡的
Alice: I slept at around 3 AM yesterday.
Tasha: 他每天只需要睡4个小时
Tasha: He only needs 4 hours of sleep every day.
Alice:no那是以前
Alice: No, that was before.
Jake:应该是你的摸错了是吧
Jake: It must be yours, right?
Katrina: 不是我是那个苹果壳
Katrina: No, I'm the one with the Apple case.
Jake:哎
Jake: Oh.
Katrina: 哎哎哎苹果壳在这我试试
Katrina: Oh, oh, oh, the Apple case is here, let me try.
Jake:明天还要买什么呀
Jake: What do we need to buy tomorrow?
Katrina: 不用买呀
Katrina: We don't need to buy anything.
Jake:薄荷叶
Jake: Mint leaves.
Alice:我觉得鸡蛋需要补充一下哈哈
Alice: I think we need to replenish the eggs, haha.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:鸡蛋
Jake: Eggs.
Katrina: 停止外送旺仔牛奶
Katrina: Stop delivering Wangzai milk.
Katrina: 这两个34G的下单
Katrina: Order these two 34G ones.
Lucia: 哼哼
Lucia: Hmph.
Tasha: 哼哼
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Katrina: 时钟你买是吧
Katrina: You're buying the clock, right?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Katrina: 这个我买了
Katrina: I bought this one.
Alice:这个蛋糕坯烤得还挺好吃的就是奶油有点
Alice: This cake base is really tasty, but the cream is a bit...
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Katrina: 234 他买就行
Katrina: 234, he can buy it.
Alice:今晚上是不是又要看那个装修
Alice: Are we watching that renovation show again tonight?
Alice:装 哦不 装饰
Alice: Renova- oh no, decoration.
Katrina: 还要看一下跳什么舞
Katrina: We also need to see which dance to do.
Jake:嗯对跳跳舞
Jake: Yeah, let's dance.
Alice:装饰的
Alice: The decoration one.
Jake:装饰的装饰一下
Jake: Yeah, let's decorate.
Jake:装饰
Jake: Decorate.
Alice:我想跟你睡一起了
Alice: I want to sleep with you.
Alice:我可以抄你的作业
Alice: Can I copy your homework?
Jake:装饰
Jake: Decorate.
Jake:装修的话
Jake: If it's about renovation...
Lucia: 我刚才也在想
Lucia: I was just thinking...
Lucia: 有没有哪位同学把自己的房间装修
Lucia: Has any student renovated their room...
Lucia: 给我抄一抄
Lucia: so I can copy it?
Jake:哈哈对
Jake: Haha, yeah.
Jake:装修可能讨论讨论
Jake: We can discuss renovation.
Katrina: 小红书照着买吧
Katrina: Let's just buy from Xiaohongshu.
Jake:就是多开个PPT开个投影
Jake: Yeah, open a PPT, use a projector.
Jake:聊聊天看看图之类的
Jake: Chat and look at some pictures.
Alice:啊怎么
Alice: Ah, how...
Alice:啊看看组
Alice: Ah, look at the group...
Jake:是看看图看看图
Jake: Yeah, look at pictures.
Alice:哦看看图
Alice: Oh, look at pictures.
Jake:刷刷网页
Jake: Browse the web.
Alice:不是自己的房间吗
Alice: Not our own rooms?
Jake:对啊互相扯扯
Jake: Yeah, just chat.
Jake:就是就互相扯扯
Jake: Just chat with each other.
Lucia: 我们做完设计以后还要做一个PPT
Lucia: After we finish designing, we need to make a PPT.
Lucia: 向大家汇报一下吗
Lucia: Should we give everyone an update?
Jake:呃PPT不用做
Jake: Uh, no need to make a PPT.
Tasha: 哦那我就放
Tasha: Oh, then I'll just...
Jake:就看网页就好了
Jake: Just look at the webpage.
Lucia: 啊哦
Lucia: Oh, alright.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Katrina: 看网页
Katrina: Look at the webpage.
Katrina: 直接用这个
Katrina: Just use this.
Katrina: 看手机不就行了
Katrina: Can't we just look at our phones?
Jake:哦也对
Jake: Oh, right.
Katrina: 嗯对吧
Katrina: Yeah, right?
Jake:就是手机互相传阅是吧
Jake: So, we just pass the phones around, right?
Katrina: 为什么要看别人的
Katrina: Why look at others'?
Jake:你自己看是吧
Jake: Just look at your own, right?
Katrina: 嗯嗯
Katrina: Yeah, yeah.
Jake:哦你们要偷偷的自己搞
Jake: Oh, you guys want to secretly do it yourselves.
Jake:不跟别人分享
Jake: Not sharing with others.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake:你原来是
Jake: So you were...
Alice:那我的应该是花里胡哨乱搞风
Alice: Then mine should be flashy and chaotic.
Jake:应该是
Jake: Should be.
Katrina: 倒也不是
Katrina: Not really.
Katrina: 我也是我要搞五颜六色
Katrina: I also want to make it colorful.
Lucia: 可是墙上不能贴的话
Lucia: But if we can't put anything on the wall,
Lucia: 我在想我应该怎么弄
Lucia: I'm thinking about how I should do it.
Katrina: 美文纸明天叫个外送看看
Katrina: Order some decorative paper for delivery tomorrow and see.
Katrina: 如果他要是真的效果挺好的话就可以
Katrina: If it looks good, then we can use it.
Jake:你们都吃完了
Jake: Have you all finished eating?
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Jake:就剩我一个了
Jake: I'm the only one left.
Katrina: 韩胜萍没吃
Katrina: Han Shengping hasn't eaten.
Katrina: 我
Katrina: I...
Katrina: 我还有一个
Katrina: I still have one more.
Katrina: 我等会我等会
Katrina: I'll wait, I'll wait.
Katrina: 工作一会我又饿了
Katrina: I'll work a bit and then I'll be hungry again.
Tasha: 工作
Tasha: Work.
Jake:对工作工作
Jake: Yeah, work, work.
Katrina: 就是现在还没有消化
Katrina: I haven't digested yet.
Katrina: 我是那种吃的很少
Katrina: I eat very little.
Katrina: 但是我就是呃就是
Katrina: But I'm just, um, just...
Katrina: 额吃的少但是也饱的快
Katrina: Um, I eat less but get full quickly.
Katrina: 饱的快小鸟胃马上又又饿了
Katrina: I get full quickly, little bird stomach, and then get hungry again soon.
Alice:小鸟胃
Alice: Little bird stomach.
Katrina: 饿的也快
Katrina: I also get hungry quickly.
Alice:小鸟胃
Alice: Little bird stomach.
Lucia: 好难想啊
Lucia: It's so hard to think.
Alice:好折磨我呀
Alice: It's really torturing me.
Lucia: 为什么我们突然播出了这个环节呢
Lucia: Why are we suddenly broadcasting this segment?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:我看一下
Jake: Let me take a look.
Jake:我们用完之后
Jake: After we use it.
Alice:用完之后没
Alice: After using it, no?
Jake:我们的计划
Jake: Our plan.
Alice:这些东西
Alice: These things.
Jake:我们给你们的保底计划
Jake: Our guaranteed plan for you.
Katrina: 拿一个那种可以带嘴飞
Katrina: Take one that can fly with its mouth.
Jake:我们原来是说我们会出一个方案
Jake: We originally said we would come up with a plan.
Jake:然后如果你们这个方案能你
Jake: And if you guys can use that plan.
Jake:你们能整个挪活的话
Jake: If you can make it work.
Jake:那就用你们的方案
Jake: Then we'll use your plan.
Jake:就是我们尽量的整活
Jake: We'll do our best to make it work.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah.
Katrina: 啊 出去玩去吧
Katrina: Ah, let's go out and have fun.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Alice:那这些东西
Alice: Then these things.
Alice:扔哪去
Alice: Where to throw them?
Katrina: 什么
Katrina: What?
Alice:就是用完之后的
Alice: The things after using them.
Alice:没用完的
Alice: The unused ones.
Katrina: 不知道哎
Katrina: No idea.
Lucia: 好饱啊哈哈哈
Lucia: So full, hahaha.
Katrina: 干哈去
Katrina: What to do?
Lucia: 哈哈突然出现啊
Lucia: Haha, suddenly appeared.
Alice:你好呀
Alice: Hi there.
Alice:啊被你吓了一跳
Alice: Ah, you scared me.
Katrina: 挑一挑
Katrina: Pick one.
Lucia: 不好意思
Lucia: Sorry.
Alice:呵
Alice: Hehe.
Lucia: 因为懒得把这挪走
Lucia: Because I'm too lazy to move it.
Lucia: 就直接坐在这个小马上了
Lucia: Just sit directly on this little horse.
Alice:是不是该刷碗了
Alice: Should we do the dishes?
Tasha: 呵呵呵
Tasha: Hehehe
Alice:好痛苦啊
Alice: It's so painful.
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah
Tasha: 杨老师会刷
Tasha: Jake will do the dishes.
Alice:真嘟假嘟
Alice: Really?
Tasha: 真的
Tasha: Really.
Alice:我们外卖还没扔呢
Alice: We haven't thrown out the takeout yet.
Tasha: 外卖
Tasha: Takeout.
Lucia: 额对我们剩的外卖还没有收拾
Lucia: Yeah, we haven't cleaned up the leftover takeout.
Alice:上边的
Alice: The one on top.
Alice:还没收拾
Alice: We haven't cleaned it up yet.
小薇 ：杨老师昨天收拾的
Tasha: Jake cleaned it up yesterday.
Jake:啊什么东西
Jake: What is it?
Tasha: 是吧
Tasha: Right?
Lucia: 咦嘻哈哈哈
Lucia: Hee hee hahaha
Jake:什么东西
Jake: What is it?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
爱丽是吗
Alice: Really?
Jake:啥
Jake: What?
Katrina: 啥
Katrina: What?
Tasha: 是吧
Tasha: Right?
Jake:是啊什么东西
Jake: Yeah, what is it?
Lucia: 什么呀
Lucia: What is it?
Tasha: 你看是啊
Tasha: You see, right?
Jake:是啥呀
Jake: What is it?
Lucia: 哈哈哈打哑谜
Lucia: Hahaha, playing riddles.
Tasha: 他说你会把这东西都洗掉
Tasha: He said you would clean all this stuff.
Jake:呵
Jake: Huh
Jake:哦哦哦哈哈好行呵呵
Jake: Oh, oh, oh, haha, okay, sure, hehe.
Tasha: 呵呵
Tasha: Hehe
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Hey
Jake:我们给你们
Jake: We have something for you.
Jake:我们有一些proposal
Jake: We have some proposals.
Jake:一个是
Jake: One is...
Lucia: 说来听听
Lucia: Tell us.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:嗯也不是
Jake: Well, not really.
Jake:就是这中间几天怎么整活了
Jake: So how are we going to plan these few days?
Jake:一些proposal
Jake: Some proposals.
Alice:哎眼镜呢
Alice: Hey, where are my glasses?
Jake:额
Jake: Uh...
Tasha: 哎我没有发现我哎
Tasha: Hey, I didn't notice... Hey...
Lucia: 给我们一些灵感嘛
Lucia: Give us some inspiration.
Lucia: 说不定我们听了之后会有更多的ID的
Lucia: Maybe we'll come up with more ideas after hearing you out.
Jake:对好的好的
Jake: Yeah, sure, sure.
Jake:哎你的
Jake: Hey, your...
Jake:你的眼镜好了
Jake: Your glasses are ready.
Katrina: 我的风铃挂在哪里呢
Katrina: Where should I hang my wind chime?
Lucia: 网好差呀
Lucia: The internet is so bad.
Katrina: 刷不出东西
Katrina: I can't load anything.
Jake:哎老三呢
Jake: Hey, where's the third one?
Alice:上楼了拿东西去了
Alice: Went upstairs to get something.
Jake:这是他手机
Jake: This is his phone.
Alice:是的吧
Alice: I think so.
Jake:你给他带上
Jake: Take it to him.
Lucia: 咱这有洗衣机吗
Lucia: Do we have a washing machine?
Jake:有就在那边
Jake: Yes, it's over there.
Lucia: 看看这个
Lucia: Look at this.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 啊他前面被堵住了
Lucia: Ah, it's blocked in the front.
Lucia: 门口应该有个灯
Lucia: There should be a light at the entrance.
Lucia: 让我研究一下
Lucia: Let me figure it out.
Lucia: 咱们需要洗衣服的数据吗
Lucia: Do we need washing machine data?
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake:呃可以有
Jake: Uh, sure.
Jake:可以洗
Jake: You can wash it.
Lucia: 因为我想把我这个裤子洗一下
Lucia: Because I want to wash these pants.
Lucia: 不过我光手洗一下
Lucia: But I'll just hand wash it.
Lucia: 那个沾到沾到奶油的地方
Lucia: The spot that got cream on it.
Jake:那也可以用它 对
Jake: You can use it too. Yeah.
Lucia: 或者就是直接撂进去
Lucia: Or just throw it in there.
Lucia: 他这有洗衣液
Lucia: There's detergent here.
Lucia: 哎还真有
Lucia: Oh, there really is.
Jake:有
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 啊好全啊
Lucia: Wow, it's so complete.
Lucia: 嗯啊
Lucia: Mm-hmm.
Katrina: 好香啊让我想想
Katrina: It smells so good, let me think.
Lucia: 那我又要上去一下了
Lucia: Then I need to go up again.
Lucia: 让我换个裤子就下来
Lucia: Let me change my pants and I'll come down.
Jake:有一个火锅抽奖   抽食材
Jake: There's a hot pot raffle to pick ingredients.
Lucia: 抽食材
Lucia: Pick ingredients.
Jake:抽抽到什么吃什么
Jake: Whatever you pick, you eat.
Lucia: 听着好像呃
Lucia: Sounds like, um...
Jake:哈哈就是这个意思
Jake: Haha, that's the idea.
Tasha: 噔噔噔噔噔噔米噔噔
Tasha: Dun dun dun dun dun dun mi dun dun.
Tasha: 就是
Tasha: Exactly.
Alice:你的眼镜好了
Alice: Your glasses are ready.
Jake:是的
Jake: Yes.
Alice:me
Alice: Me.
Jake:you
Jake: You.
Katrina: 这也是要自己做啊
Katrina: This also needs to be done by ourselves?
Lucia: 来观摩一下
Lucia: Coming to observe.
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 来观摩一下你打算怎么改造你的房间
Lucia: Coming to observe how you plan to renovate your room.
Tasha: 首先先把屏量放这
Tasha: First, put the screen here.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Hehe.
Jake:我去
Jake: Oh my.
Katrina: 设计专业的
Katrina: Design major.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Lucia: 哈哈procreate专业
Lucia: Haha, procreate major.
Jake:完了你设计完估计还要做president大家
Jake: After you're done designing, you'll probably need to present it to everyone.
Alice:什么president
Alice: What presentation?
Katrina: 别吓唬他
Katrina: Don't scare him.
Jake:就是要
Jake: It's just that.
Jake:呃秀硕给你讲一遍
Jake: Uh, Shure will explain it to you.
Jake:就是秀硕把你的房间帮你讲一遍
Jake: Shure will explain your room to you.
Jake:哈哈哈啊
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Jake:没有没有没有乱说
Jake: No, no, no, just kidding.
Lucia: 我们还有这个环节
Lucia: We have this segment too?
Jake:没有没有
Jake: No, no.
Jake:就是我我就是说
Jake: I'm just saying.
Jake:他可能最后能做出个视频出来
Jake: He might end up making a video like yesterday's.